all right this one is for our seniors
it's healthcare that makes you the
center of attention take a look
talk to us about central introduce us to
what you guys do for the community
so center well is a senior focused
primary care group
throughout the las vegas valley so we
really emphasize
you know uh spending special attention
on our seniors in general
and what does center well mean
so we used to be called actually
partners in primary care but we actually
changed the name to center well really
to focus on a couple aspects in the
sense that
first of all we put our patients in the
center of the care
and want to focus on them particularly
and also
wellness right it's not just treating
illness but it's also
maintaining a level of wellness for our
patients so it really
the name now really represents that
combination of both of those elements
well i actually love the name change i
was with you in your doc
in your office when you were called
primary care in your beautiful facility
um and i understand that senior focused
care is also one of your
primary fact i guess your foundation so
explain what that means for everybody
so we know that as we all age we have
different needs
um in maintaining our health and also
more
um chance of suffering from chronic
illnesses so
for us it's really about focusing on
that particular population and having
those special needs addressed
that we have as we grow older so for us
it's you know developing clinics that
not only
you know physically meet the needs of
our patients whether it's if they have
mobility issues or other issues
but it's also about addressing all the
elements that keep
you know our seniors well whether it's
financial social
emotional all of those components are
you know
engaged in our clinics we actually have
what we call a resource coordinator who
helps our seniors focus on
needs they may have outside of their
medical needs maybe it's
you know housing insecurity or the need
to
you know enroll in certain low-income
resources so that they can get their
prescriptions at better
at better prices for them so it's really
about overcoming some of those barriers
that are often you know insurmountable
for our patients to overcome to
to really get their needs met i
understand each location has a care team
what do they consist of so we're really
lucky we have not only the
traditional elements of a care team like
physicians medical assistants front
office
but we also have rns who help manage you
know some of the patients
um needs as well as we have a clinical
pharmacist on staff
to you know help patients work with
their uh
medications to get the you know the best
costing or the most cost effective
medications that they can be on because
even as physicians we we don't
necessarily know
everything so it's really having the
talents of
all these team members to to make the
care accessible for our patients and
optimized
well speaking of accessible i you guys
are across the valley where can people
find center well
so center well right now we currently
have eight locations
and um throughout the valley and we look
to be opening two more by the end of
this year
for more information on center well
senior primary care call 702-766-4910
or visit seniorfocuslasvegas.com